let's just play the game let's say you
know it was explosive let's say this was
you know planned let's say a group of
people come to you and say hey you know
Richard we would like to figure out a
way how to you know get World Trade
Center to come down vertically all the
way down what supplies do we need how
much preparation do we need how much
Manpower do we need how do we need to
get past the security to get in there to
set them up exactly in the corners that
they need to be set up how much money do
we need to invest and out of all this
crew that work together can we find
these few hundred people that can get
this job done to keep a secret for the
rest of their lives that this never
happened what does it take for us to do
something like this what would you say
to them fair question and we have to
start with how we want the Twin Towers
to come down
and we have I wanted to come down the
way it came down yeah yeah and and we're
looking at building seven here but in
the case of the Twin Towers the official
narrative tells us that the top part
drove the rest of the building down to
the ground sure and then destroyed
itself well how do you do that
um first of all that's not what happened
the top part is destroying itself in the
first four seconds you can see it in the
videos it's very clear the top part is
this the structural steel is actually
being liquefied if you will and and so
what happens after that by the way 156
First Responders are hearing explosions
this is in the oral histories uh
produced by Thomas vonession the fire
commissioner they're hearing explosions
uh before the tower ever collapses this
is research by Professor Graham McQueen
it's incredible
um and you wouldn't want that to be a
part of your story but there's certain
things you can't get away with when
you're planning this event but after
that first four seconds in each of these
towers we have
laterally ejected freely flying
structural steel sections weighing four
and eight tons
80 miles an hour out of the tower
laterally Landing 600 feet in every
direction destroying many buildings
around them
that's incredible this is not like a
banana peeling like the debunkers like
like to say so uh we're getting at at
how you you bring the building down but
we have to look at how it actually came
down first we have squibs or isolated
explosive ejections occurring 20 40 60
stories down below this destruction zone
so so how can that be accounted for also
in the official narrative it cannot and
then we have the complete shattering of
the structure something that the
National Fire Protection Association
guide 921 says look for uh in your
investigation of explosions and fires
look for the shattering the structure
debris thrown great distances that's
what exactly what we find and down at
the bottom what do we see because
everything the the structural steel is
ejected so far laterally we have at the
bottom of the pile on only a two-story
pile of miscellaneous Twisted Metal
well where did the steel what crushed
the building if the steel is 600 foot
diameter all around each of the
perimeter of these towers during the
course of its destruction in the air
that's 90 no it's a hundred thousand
tons of structural steel in each Tower
not contributing to the collapse of this
building maybe it's the concrete floors
each of them were four and eight inches
thick on various floors and an acre in
size but we look again at the at the
videos and we see the complete
pulverization of this concrete which is
across Lower Manhattan in a three square
mile area
wait a minute if the concrete is in a
blanket three inches thick across from
River to River across lower Manhattan
what's crushing the building
this is happening during not afterward
during the course of the built of the
buildings serious series of explosions
which are also visible on on the videos
so we have two-thirds the weight of the
building that's not even available to
crush the building and zedenic bazant of
Chicago Northwestern University uh came
out two days after 9 11 with his theory
which was so obfuscated that it took
Engineers almost a decade to crack and
when they did they find that not only
did he use all the steel and all the
concrete in the weight but he multiplied
at times three it's a complete
fraudulent attempt to try to explain
mathematically because he's a
mathematical wizard how this building
was destroyed and it Remains the key
theoretical basis for nist's column
failure Theory so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]